let's say I've got a sequence starts at
one then let's it goes to negative 1/2
then it goes to positive 1/3 then it
goes to negative 1/4 then it goes to
positive 1/5 and it just keeps going on
and on and on like this and we could
graph it let me draw our vertical axis
so I'll graph this is our y-axis and I'm
going to graph y is equal to a sub N and
let's make this our this is a horizontal
axis where I'm going to plot our ends so
this right over here is our ends and
this is let's say this is right over
here is positive 1 this right over here
is negative 1 this would be negative 1/2
this would be positive 1/2 I'm not
drawing it I'm not drawing the vertical
and horizontal axes at the same scale
just so that we can kind of visualize
this properly but let's say this is 1 2
3 4 5 and I could keep going on and on
and on so we see here that when n is
equal to 1 a sub n is equal to 1 so this
is right over there so when n is equal
to 1 a sub n is equal to 1 so this is y
is equal to a sub n now when n is equal
to when n is equal to 2 we have a sub n
is equal to negative 1/2 when n is equal
to 2 a sub n is equal to negative is
equal to negative 1/2 when n is equal to
3 a sub n is equal to 1/3 it's equal to
1/3 which is right about right about
there when n is equal to 4 a sub n is
equal to negative 1/4 which is right
about right about there and then when n
is equal to 5 a sub n is equal to
positive 1/5 which is maybe right over
there and we keep going on and on and on
so you see the points they kind of jump
around but they seem to be getting
closer and closer and closer to 0 which
a switch would make us ask a very
natural question what happens to a sub n
as n approaches infinity or another way
of saying that is what is the limit let
me just
color what is the limit of a sub n as n
approaches infinity well let's think
about if we can if we can define a sub n
explicitly explicitly if we can define
the sequence explicitly so we can define
the sequence as a sub n where n starts
at 1 and goes to infinity with with a
sub n equaling what is it equal well if
we ignore sine for a second it looks
like it's just 1 over n but then it's we
seem like we oscillate in signs we start
with a positive then a negative positive
negative so we could multiply this times
negative 1 to the let's see if we
multiply times negative 1 to the n then
this one would be negative and this one
would be positive but we don't want it
that way we want the first term to be
positive so we could say negative 1 to
the n plus 1 power and you can verify
this works when n is equal to 1 you have
1 times negative 1 squared which is just
1 and they'll work for all the rest we
could write this as equaling negative 1
to the n plus 1 power over n and so
asking what the limit of a sub n as n
approaches infinity is is equivalent to
asking what is the limit of negative 1
to the n plus 1 power over n as n
approaches infinity is going to be equal
to remember a sub n this is just a
function of n it's a function where
we're limited right over here to
positive integers as our domain but this
is still just a limit as something
approaches infinity and I haven't
rigorously defined it yet but you can
think you can conceptualize what's going
on here as n approaches infinity the
numerator is going to oscillate between
positive and negative 1 but this
denominator is going to get bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger so we're
gonna get really really really really
small numbers and so this thing right
over here is going to is going to
approach 0 now I have not proved this to
it yet I am just claiming that this is
true but the if this is true if this
true so let me write this down if true
if true if the limit of a sub n is n
approaches infinity is 0 then we say
then we can say that a sub n converges
converges to zero that's another way of
saying this right over here if it didn't
if it just if if the limit as n
approaches infinity didn't go to some
value right here and I haven't
rigorously defined how we define a limit
but if this was not true if we could not
set some limit what doesn't have to be
equal to zero as long as if this was not
equal to some number then we would say
that a sub n diverges